how are you Kurt I am doing extremely
well another good game last night and
it's just fun time of year I love that
all these games have such big
implications and we're going to be
talking about every single game and all
these teams moving forward it's just fun
time of year I mean last night had
everything from like a Plinko chip
interception returned for 6 against
Seattle and then Seattle going on a huge
momentum swing to take a lead and then
realizing that perhaps punting the ball
might stunt the momentum and fake
punting I mean that had everything last
night Curt it it did you know I mean you
know we talked about it and you know
sometimes we look from the outside but
when you actually played the game that
hole that we call big momentum is a real
thing and you know it's tough to stop
when the other team has it but once you
gain it back you know it's difficult to
overcome and so when you have teams that
are able to do that kind of weather the
storms and and overcome it and make big
plays in Seattle just seems to be one of
the best teams in the league at doing
that there's never any panic and you
know so often they find themselves down
or behind early in games and they just
they don't panic they just weather the
storm they know they're gonna get an
opportunity and then when they do they
take advantage of it and I think that's
you know it's all about leadership guys
like Russell Wilson and and Pete Carroll
are so good at staying upbeat and
positive in those situations and we saw
that last night and you know and I
thought oh gosh no way Minnesota's going
to come back and then they make a couple
great drives and make the thing
interesting down the thread so you're
right it was it was a fun game knowing
that both teams needed it really badly
there was a fun game to call and watch
because there was a lot of big game
changing type plays within the game and
you know it's also that building to Curt
and it's also the time of night a
prime-time game in that building with
the 12s it really is something to see
momentum going and then when they when
they when they come up with a big play
it just charges the whole building and
now they're in a bi-week position to cut
to self control it the rest
the way how viable are the Seahawks to
you to win it all this year Kirk you
know it's interesting because you know I
was kind of looking at that with the NFC
and I still you know every week I mean I
you know I lone wolf Minnesota this week
because I watch Seattle and I don't
think they're a great team top to bottom
I don't think they have a bunch of great
players and so you
I kind of always wait for things to
catch up with them the defense isn't
quite as good and you know they've got
some issues and they give up some plays
and offensively they're not great at
passing the football even though they're
really good at running it and I just
think okay it's gonna catch up to him we
get playing another good team yet they
continue to find ways to win and so I
look around the NFC and I still think
the same thing about data I think man
teams like San Francisco or more
balanced seems like New Orleans are more
balanced but I think those are the only
two teams I look at and say Seattle and
again I'd only one that say Seattle
can't beat them they've already you know
beaten San Francisco at San Francisco so
we know they can but I look at those two
teams and say I think they're more
complete teams than Seattle is and so I
put Seattle probably at the number three
position in terms of going to the
Superbowl but you have Russell Wilson
and as you said if you're playing in
that building I mean if you end up
getting the number one seed and play in
that building with those fans they are
gonna keep it close and Russell is gonna
have a chance to win those games late
and I think they are a viable option
even though I don't put them at the
number one spot you know because of how
I look at their entire team and then you
know there's there are the Saints
sitting out there too I know we're all
focused on the 49ers certainly because
they just took care of business against
order they almost took care of business
against the Ravens that Teddy
Bridgewater first start man happened up
in Seattle and that might be the
tiebreak that sends everything through
the Superdome as I mentioned at the top
of the show today and and and I know
that the Saints have been so-called
struggling against some division
opponents lately I'm wondering what do
you see on film I want to get into some
of your film study about the Saints and
how
they can be equipped to win it all this
year themselves well I think you know
again with the Saints I don't know if
from top to bottom I say they're a great
team but I do believe that they can beat
you different ways I think they can stop
the run they can get after you with
their defensive front cam Jordan you
know leading the charge there I believe
they can run the football they've got a
good offensive line they have the
ability to run the football we saw that
at different times this year especially
when you know when Drew was out a little
bit and Murray came in he ran the
football extremely well went over a
hundred yards a couple times and then
you still have camara Drew Brees is
still Drew Brees and you know Michael
Thomas is as good as they get so they've
got some really good pieces and some lot
lots of ways to beat you when I watch
them know something just doesn't seem to
be clicking perfectly for them yet and
thus the reasons that they struggle a
little bit or you know like last week
they they got way up on you know
Carolina and then Carolina comes all the
way back and really has a chance to beat
them and they hold on it and win in the
end
you know it's things like that or it's
like that's not the Saints team that
I've come to to expect but I'd still do
believe you know when you look at the
totality of their team that the second
best team in the NFC I believe behind
San Francisco and it's gonna be a great
matchup I mean those two teams play this
weekend and you mentioned it how huge
San Francisco going from the 1 seed to
the 5 seed and now they have you know to
play in New Orleans and New Orleans
sitting up there at the the 1 spot and
as you know that chance to take control
but San Francisco I think could very
easily beat New Orleans and throw this
thing all a lot of whack and as you said
put Seattle up there the number one spot
with those two teams having a matchup in
Seattle
later in the year I mean I just love
where we're at and I do like New Orleans
but I just when I watch the film
something just is off a little bit with
them that I'm not ready to say that
their world beaters quite yet maybe
because we haven't seen the camara
dominating performance all year but one
where he can't be stopped where he's
coming out of the backfield is a matchup
nightmare or just running over people we
haven't
seen that yet and and maybe he hasn't
right physically or it's more of a
Michael Thomas offense maybe that's what
you're you're missing by seeing them
right now yeah you know and I think just
having it all clicking is what I'm
waiting for
okay as we said you know there's times
they run really well there's times where
they just they dominate in the air they
throw it to Michael Thomas but yeah I
haven't seen all those pieces which we
know are really talented come together
and play well at the same time and then
just dominate people as of late and I
think they have the capabilities of
doing that haven't done it yet and I
agree I think that's what I'm waiting
Kurt Warner here on the Rich Eisen show
Macon is way out of Seattle
so there's five ten and two teams which
is amazing you've already mentioned two
in the Saints in Seattle not being from
your opinion great from top to bottom
which one is is one in your opinion you
said you already said that the Seahawks
and the and the Saints are not great
teams top to bottom from using is there
a 10 and 2 team in your mind that is
which one is well I tell you what I do
like two of the teams and I like those
two teams we saw last week in in
Baltimore in San Francisco I thought
that was a great football game I thought
it lived up to the billing
two teams that I believe can beat you in
any way shape or form they can beat you
on defense they can beat you running the
football and the quarterbacks have shown
they can make enough big plays to beat
you through the air as a complementary
piece I thought San Francisco was
affected more by the weather last week
then Baltimore was and that was the
difference in the game when I went back
and watched the tape I really felt like
San Francisco could have easily won that
game and I didn't know if I was gonna
say that going in because I thought
Baltimore was that hot but I believe
those are the two best teams in football
and the most complete teams and you know
have pieces to be able to do a lot of
different things and so I know five
teams up there at 10:00 and 2:00 but I
would say those two teams in my opinion
are the two best teams in football right
now which what did the tape reveal from
Patriots Texans for you Kirk
well a couple things first of all I
didn't help the Texans had that inner to
go against a good Patriots team and
specifically a good Patriots defense and
stand up and show up the way that they
did and really dominates offensively I
mean deshaun Watson was incredible on
schedule and an incredible as usual off
schedule didn't know if he was going to
be able to do that on schedule as well
as he he did they dominated up front
which surprised me as well and then I
think the other side of it that real um
Romeo Crennel and company did a great
job of calling that game and there were
certain times that I just wrote on my
notes perfect defense you know whatever
it was against that you know
particularly run or that particular pass
they just had the perfect defense
numerous times but I think the bigger
issue there is the Patriots offenses is
just a mess right now
and I know the narratives been thrown
out there that Oh nobody's open well I
disagree with that I went back and
watched the film and I thought there was
a lot of guys open and now everybody
wants to say well that means that it's
all Tom Brady no it's not old Tom Brady
but there is some blame to go to Tom
Brady but I think there's times at
scheme there's times that it's it's
their offensive line the others times
that it serve receivers and there's
times that it's Tom Brady and I think
the fact that things aren't working very
well it kind of talked about this on the
show last week the fact that things
aren't working very well
has Tom so frustrated that he gets off
of Reed sometimes too early as guys are
getting open or he forces balls to
certain guys you know that he knows a
little bit better instead of allowing
the defense to tell him to where to go
with the football there's times in the
game where I couldn't figure out why he
was looking a certain direction instead
of another direction and then of course
there's times when he's looking for guys
are expecting guys to do something and
they don't do the right thing and so you
put all that together and you put it the
ball in somebody's hands it's a very
tough place to be when you're not really
sure what you're gonna get you're not
really sure how long the protections
gonna last and how long I can wait on a
receiver and this receiver didn't do the
right thing the last time so can I wait
on them because the defense is telling
me I suppose to throw it to them can I
wait on them this time and expect him to
do the right thing
I'm not going to I'm gonna go away from
it yet then that guy gets open this time
and so it's a tough place to be and I
just think it's it's different for Tom
Brady he's used to scheming guys open
he's used to being able to look at Clark
out there and even if cross somewhat
covered say huh I can still throw it to
Gronk and make a play because I know I'm
good enough to throw it where I want to
throw it and Gronk's good enough to win
that matchup or get the football and so
he's been used to kind of jamming it in
sometimes to his number one read with
good players and right now they don't
have those kind of players so you have
to go through progressions more and you
got to get through things a little bit
faster and you got to be a little more
patient with things and I think that's
what's throwing their offense off right
now Wow
alright before I let you go that's quite
a mouthful so look you eat Brady's neck
up got so much experience as we know I
mean I don't even need to set this up
bail a check they probably see this in
real time they might not even need to
see the film in real time so what's the
fix what's the fix here you know what's
wrong that's a great question and you
know as I always say if you can pinpoint
one thing as the problem I think it's
easy to go and okay we're gonna address
this and we're gonna figure out how we
can fix this one area the biggest
problem is there's too many areas right
now and so I don't know how you fix all
of those areas you know these young guys
you know to get them up to speed your
offensive line to know how to protect
them so they can protect Tom Brady you
know Tom Brady and that - you said he's
so good from the neck up but to get him
to settle in and understand he's got to
play the game a little bit differently
now because he doesn't have the same
weapons that is a whole bunch of stuff
you have to correct at one particular
time and so I don't really know the
answer I don't know how you fix you know
four or five different issues where
everybody's taking their turn how you
fix that quickly I think it's just going
to take time and the question will be do
they have enough time to kind of wait
this thing out and at some point hit a
bit of a stride or even though they're
going to depend on their defense more
they can do enough all sensibly come
playoff time to beat some of these good
offensive football teacher all right so
looking over the last one for you Kurt
looking over the week fourteen steering
wheel which one I'll give you four
options which one features the biggest
chance of an upset
Cowboys bears and we all know even
though they're each six and six what the
upset would be with our the guy to your
left on on game day morning set then
you've got that one Ravens bills Chiefs
Patriots Seahawks Rams and we all know
what the upset would be in Chiefs
Patriots two despite how red-hot mahomes
looked against the Raiders what do you
got for me well in those scenarios I'm
going Chiefs you know their defense is
starting to become a little more
opportunistic and I think what we've
seen with the Patriots is that when you
have teams that can score on them that's
what's giving them problems so the
Ravens jumped out early on them scoring
wise and they were able to get back into
it
the Texans jumped out early on them
scoring wise and they couldn't get back
into it because their offense isn't
working
I believe the Chiefs we saw it you know
last year that they can school on this
defense and they've got the playmakers
in one-on-one situations to do that but
I believe they can jump out them jump
out on them and score some points and
force Tom Brady and company to keep up
with them and that's a means it's not a
good scenario right now with where the
Patriots are so I'm definitely going
Chiefs with that all right well and then
also just a front load for our Saturday
meeting for Sunday game day morning even
even with whatever happens for cowboys
bears while you were making your way to
the airport Jerry Jones spoke on his
radio show today Kurt and had this to
say about Jason Garrett being qualified
to win a Super Bowl and which coach
would be if not him he said this quote
nobody has the exclusive skills to get
the job done so that collectively you
can win a Super Bowl but there are
qualified people Jason Garrett is one of
them in my opinion Jason Garrett will be
coaching in the NFL next year will be
coaching in the NFL nation and then he
left it at that yeah yeah
so basically curtain Kurt Kurt he could
be coaching the Cowboys and if not he
can use Jerry as a reference
well that sounds like a good reference I
mean yeah he's got a lot of love for him
he's got a bust in the same room as you
right yes he does
one of my classmates all right well get
ready for that conversation it's coming
it's coming man I can't wait all right
wait currently if they play Thursday
they do I mean and that's so much on the
line right there all right last one for
you I lied true Biscay what do you think
what's going on with him what do you
what are you seeing there ah well I mean
I think the bottom line is he's still
growing you know that I don't think
we've seen everything that mitch is
gonna show us throughout the course of
his career you know talked about it the
last couple weeks he's one of those that
really I struggle with because he makes
some really good plays and you know he
excites you at times and you've seen
games where he can put games together
Rico man this kid has a chance once he
settles in and grows into the position
and then you see and then you see the
other the other side where you're just
like what are you doing what are you
looking at so you know again I don't
know how long you can wait with a guy
like that kind of like a Jameis Winston
you see enough that excites you you see
enough that makes you shake your head
and throw your hands up and I think
mitch is still at that point I think the
question simply becomes what's that
cutoff point where I need to see more
consistency from them because we just
don't see it right now boy Thursday
night's gonna be amazing last night was
terrific to Curt I listened to much of
it great job and I'll see you in a few
days
all right buddy you gotta wait you got
you gotta that's Kurt Warner for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on VR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app